i'm thinking about getting a
three-wheeled harley oh really that's
weird i didn't know you
know you were delicate like that now
do you have any excuses
oh three-wheel yeah are you serious
yeah why the [ __ ] would you do that
because i don't trust myself on two
wheels i don't trust him on two wheels
like three no no now we're talking yeah
i you know what now i want a three
wheeler
if you have three wheels if you have
three wheels you can't cut them between
cars and traffic yeah so you your wheels
are they're not cool yeah
no they're that's cool hey they're
they're not trust me you're like i
promise you they're not okay you're
wrong
yeah not bad what are we doing no
they're not cool don't do that
we're co-signing on the same thing here
it's not cool until me and sam started
biker
but you think that's more safe you're
right yeah dude it's like it's [ __ ]
balanced better but the problem is not
about it's not about you being safe it's
the drivers other [ __ ]
take me off your speed dial when you're
on that yeah like what you passed
i want one myself oh man four hundred
dollars we can't afford not to no that's
not it man listen dude the four of us
start a biker game three-wheeler biker
getting a mountain
boys biker club i'll drive a jeep i'll
ride that
guys oh you have a real motorcycle oh
i've seen that yeah you're too big to be
on a bike though yeah no this bike fits
me pretty good is it it's a crotch
rocket no no no no i got rid of that
long time okay because when i met you at
a crotch rocket
i got rid of that what do we mean 87 87
[ __ ] you you have like a straight up
what harley or something
here daddy
i see i'm a ducati guy a little classier
i don't think ducati's are classier are
they not no i don't know motorcycles
yeah no
no i'm a little worried about
motorcycles i i would die a motorcycle
just like that oh dude i could i
definitely get why people want them not
on three wheels bro i i i have a jeep
i'll drive myself on the street
dude we'll be the three wheel boys yeah
are you gonna wear a
do
helmet
you're
to wear a helmet in california yeah
because you don't have to wear them in
indiana
yeah we're we're open carry state people
like ride with ak-47s no one was like
they said they saw a guy
it's a constitutional carry said also so
everybody that has like i think you're
twenty-two vote doesn't have felonies
whatever else can carry openly
that's amazing